this morning we're hearing a new message
apparently from the reclusive leader of
Isis Abu Bakr al-baghdadi Isis lost its
last territory in Syria in March but
remains a terror threat and the dottie
called for his followers to carry out
attacks and demanded the release of Isis
prisoners Holly Williams went to a
high-security prisoner prison rather
holding Isis fighters in Syria she
brings us an exclusive report from the
northeast of the country Holly what did
you see
good morning we were actually the first
ever camera crew allowed inside this
high-security prison now you may
remember that President Trump recently
demanded that European countries take
their nationals who joined Isis here in
Syria home so what we did not expect to
find was prisoners who told us they were
American you were born in Belgium the
prison is like the United Nations you're
from Holland
we're from the Netherlands except
everyone here is accused of joining Isis
they signed up for an Islamic paradise
but ended up living fifty to a cell some
with terrible injuries from the
battlefield you're American Liam still
Imani told us he left his home in
Chicago to live under Isis in 2015 and
he's unrepentant the choices that I made
in somebody's eyes are the wrong choices
so I face jail time but they're the
wrong choices in your eyes do you think
you made the wrong choice
just wanted to live under Islamic law
there are about 5,000 prisoners inside
this Jail and the guards say many of
them are dangerous if they escape there
are fears they'll rejoin Isis insurgents
who continue to carry out attacks
they've kind of organized him to pretend
that he's C and then they've called the
guards in the guard showed us this
attempted prison break from four days
ago and then they pull the door off its
hinges and they charge even further down
the corridor they want to send a foreign
prisoners home but in most cases their
own governments don't want them back
even when they're children we met
another prisoner here who identified
himself as a 17 year old u.s. citizen
from New York City he told us his
parents took him to join Isis he didn't
want to appear on camera but like nearly
all of the foreigners here he is
desperate to leave do you want to go
back to the u.s. of course I'm gonna die
soon here I'm sick I
I do not get any medical attention if
you go back to the US you're almost
certainly facing a prison term I know
the Syrian militia group that runs the
prison along with several others told us
that if foreign governments won't take
their citizens home they should at least
help to better secure the prisons here
to prevent a mass escape Anthony Holly
Williams with some extraordinary
reporting in Syria thanks Holly